if we don't deal with climate change we
and certainly our children are in for a
very rough time we're already seeing
heat waves and extreme weather and
droughts and wildfires as a consequence
that's extremely clear i come from
california and you don't need scientists
to tell you about climate change if you
come from california it's all over the
place it really it's very obvious just
wandering around the state spring comes
a month earlier than it used to it's
much hotter in the summer there's much
less rain so there are those kinds of
consequences but but if we let this
problem continue to worsen than 20 30 40
50 years from now our children are going
to suffer a lot about half of the
world's largest cities are on coastlines
and if the Greenland ice melts then the
sea is going to rise by over 20 feet and
half of the world cities will be
underwater literally and and weather
will be far more extreme the last time
that the world was as hot as it will get
this century if we don't fix climate
change was about a hundred thousand
years ago and scientists have found
evidence of extremely destructive storms
storms that were strong enough to lift
very large boulders from the bottom of
the ocean and put them on top of
mountains so hurricane sandy is very
very minor trouble compared to what
we'll face if we don't handle this
problem but in the last decade there's
been remarkable progress in renewable
energy technology in electric cars in
sustainable agriculture and now we know
how to solve this problem and in fact we
could solve this problem in a way that
would make the world more prosperous and
healthier and happier renewable energy
is is becoming quite competitive
economically with energy from fossil
fuels within five years electric cars
electric cars will be fully competitive
with gasoline
our cars and they're much less expensive
to operate and maintain their also
quieter they also accelerate faster by
the way in most regards we could have
very useful happy productive prosperous
healthy lives by dealing with this
problem the countries in the world that
are the most prosperous and have the
most equal distribution of income and
wealth and also the longest life
expectancies are in general the
countries that are dealing best with
climate change Germany Scandinavia Japan
number of European countries and the
countries that are behaving the worst
are our countries that are very corrupt
and that have a great deal of poverty
and inequality it's not a coincidence
that countries like Venezuela and
Indonesia and Russia and Saudi Arabia
are the countries with the worst records
with regard to this problem and are also
countries that are dependent on fossil
fuels or on industrial agriculture
controlled by a very small number of
people very politically corrupt and so I
came to realize that if we deal with
political corruption will also be
dealing with climate change and
conversely if we deal with climate
change will also help the world a lot
with regard to corruption and inequality